what up space fam goes in here from
anime i'll pro back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece story
today we gotta talk about the wano
climax the fall of a yonko and the
straight up end of an era so make sure
to stay tuned for this insane chapter if
you do enjoy these one-piece chapter
reviews and want to keep them coming you
know what to do channel the pirate king
within and smash that like button with
no mercy smash it like you were lying
kids smashing big mom remember smashing
that like button is pirate king energy
and passing is scared orochi energy so
choose wisely if you haven't make this
the video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my huge one-piece
playlist that includes videos on all the
yonko warlords supernova and much more
link to that is in the description and
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and all we got an amazing
cover page for this week's shonen jump
which includes kaido's hybrid form and
luffy looking like a boss and i like how
luffy is in the red corner rather than
the blue one because red is my favorite
color maybe i just got that power king
energy out of them but another really
interesting thing is the text we're told
it's the one arc climax but also the war
that tears down an era i know we all
expect luffy's side to win already it is
shonen after all but pretty crazy
getting the magazine already practically
confirming that the old yonko era is
going to come down so on to the chapter
itself that holds the very hyped title
of and i quote the main act end quote
momo is trying to do his thing and
freaking out as per usual and we then
jump to kid and law fighting after the
events of the last chapter we're told
that big mom's been blown away some
soldiers are worried thinking big mom is
done but our side is celebrating
hilariously enough as they fight a yonko
these two meaning kid and law are still
arguing and honestly law has a pretty
good point here he says that's the
second time kid has done that aka waited
for law to use his very effective
finisher and then swooped in with a
flashy move to take the credit for
himself law insists he's not kid's
opening act and kid says who cares let
it go acting shocked that law would even
bring that up but it's totally true law
delivers his heavy internal damage and
kid comes in with a flashy awesome
looking physical move so it looks like
he just crushed big mom i love the
dynamic here and i really love kid i've
been waiting for him to really shine and
he did that somewhat last chapter but as
we'll see in a bit this is going to be
the one that really delivers with the
kid hype i've been waiting for it's
funny to see kid get into the arguing
too law asks kid to leave the final blow
to him but kid tells lot to stop giving
him orders he says there won't be
anything left of the old bat once he
hits her with his trump card the fact
that he hasn't used it yet and they got
this far already is so so hype and it
suggests kid will be the star in the end
and finally show us something
exceptional you gotta love lost jokes
though he asks what's the trump card
what comes after a bullet pack a hippo
maybe an elephant
there is the implication here that all
of kids attacks are just big and
physically strong so it'll be
interesting to see how kid responds to
this i personally would have liked to
see a mecha dragon attack too but maybe
that's just me back to yonko big mom and
boy she does not look good people are
shocked to see her bones broken but big
mom is a boss and just smiles at the
heavy damage she's received she comments
that those shock waves hit her from the
inside even broke her ribs she says
trafalgar's technique is dangerous so
signaling out the law again the story is
alluding to the fact that that kid has
to catch up somehow since law has been
better thus far and what better way to
let him shine than give him the final
finishing blow but first big mom uses
more of her life energy to bring her
bones back she's really burning through
that life energy to handle a couple of
brats as she calls them and as i keep
mentioning since she's already so old
that doesn't bode well for her there's
no telling how many times she used her
lifespan like this in the past and even
if she did win this fight somehow i
doubt she'd have many good years left
whitebeard was not that much older than
her and that's without counting the life
that big mom artificially burned through
so yeah the writings on the wall her
reign is nearing its end one way or
another for now though she looks
terrifying and she still got some fight
in her law gets serious saying he'll be
out of strength after this round the
next attack will be his last so he can't
afford to let him miss he's about to
tell kid what he'll have to do but kid
is still insisting that law needs to
stop giving him orders and all i'm
thinking is god this fight will be
amazing animated big mom combines
prometheus napoleon and hera into mazer
saber which is very cool in its own
right and cuts through kids bull calling
it nothing but useless scrap she tells
them they need to stop dreaming she sent
hundreds like them into a watery grave
and says we meaning the yonko have ruled
for decades now since the time our two
supernova were still drinking their
mother's milk that's a pretty crazy
thought but it brings up another thought
that she was in her 40s then and now
she's almost 70. you can't reign forever
our two supernova here will just make
her go into retirement a little sooner
than nature would kid uses magnetism to
pin her to the tower and the bull is
coming right at her she can't get loose
but she does a boss move of moving the
whole tower so that it blocks the impact
of the bull kit is shocked to see this
and i like that she's going down like
this continuing to impress big mom says
he's really weighed her down with this
so not only is kid distracting her he's
also slowed her down trying to make
certain that law's last attack doesn't
miss as he mentioned she summons the
attack misery or 3 000 leagues which is
kind of like her own giant weather mecca
except she doesn't need to pilot it and
it has like a living life of its own
kind of thing but the impressiveness of
the attack is short-lived the tower is
dropped on big mom then law uses his
finisher of which big mom is visibly
really afraid of his sword extends all
the way to the ground below not just the
ground of the island but the ground
below the floating island as well law
says it's gotta be deeper implying the
further down it goes the more powerful
it is his men are worried that law is
going to die since big mom is hockey
punching him but he remains focused like
a boss he unleashes the attack puncture
will a which i may have pronounced very
wrong but whatever and wow the shock
waves are crazy it looks like a meteor
hit the ground below and big mom is in a
lot of pain coughing up blood even momo
wonders how that big crater got there
big mom's living attack misery is about
to burn law to ash and then epically and
hilariously law says now eustis to which
kid has to say again in the heat of this
epic battle and right where it's about
to end how many times will i have to say
it don't tell me what to do of course
kid does it anyways though again
preparing to take the final flashy shot
and it's cool how law actually invited
him to do so this time around and the
trump card does not disappoint it's not
just a big physical move as usual he
forms a giant cannon big mom a boss in
her own right to the end tells him to
give her his best shot and kid says i am
big mom that's why i'm gonna finish you
off end quote goosebumps epicness hype
just some of what i'm feeling at this
point he launches the electromagnetic
cannon and big mom looks
done after receiving that hit we're even
told by the narrator that they are
dragging the emperors off their thrones
implying it really is over law even says
your era is over end quote i love how
you have to get the last word in of the
chapter and i wonder if kid will point
that out in the next one something like
hey that's my line but the comedic
elements aside that was epic a quick
google search of what an electromagnetic
railgun can do will show you how
fearsome kids attack must be which if
the name is at all accurate would have
no trouble ripping through a weak and
big mom so yeah it looks like we
actually took down a yonko boys i won't
even ask if you think she's down for the
count because not only did the last
attack require her to fix her bones this
time it looks like law and kids attacks
were much more formidable especially
kids also this attack can't drag on
forever and we gotta get to luffy's
fight too so i just really think it's
over right here i love to see kid
finally deliver as i was expecting him
to throughout the arc i am totally
satisfied with this victory over yonko
and i hope luffy's will be at least as
epic but hopefully oda has something
even more special in store for us and
that might be hard to believe but i am
hyped i gotta give mvp this chapter to
both law and kid i wanna give it to just
kids sort of because it was his big
moment but law taking those hits while
preparing that last attack it was just
too epic to ignore it's got to be a
shared title for me let me know your
thoughts on mvp this chapter in the
comments below and if you're satisfied
with this victory over a can't believe
i'm saying this yonko y-o-n-k-o
ionko crazy stuff and that is it for
this one if you did enjoy this review
and want to keep them coming you know
what to do chill the pirate king within
and smash that like button with no mercy
remember smashing that like button is
piraking energy and passing is scared
orochi energy so choose wisely smash
that like button like used to smash big
mom this chapter if you haven't make
this the video you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on you
guessed it all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos and updates
and while you wait for the next chapter
to drop feel free to check out my big
one piece playlist that includes videos
called the yonko warlord supernova and
much more link to that is in the
description and until next time see you
space cowboys